Rémi kukulenski ne sera pas resté bien
longtemps sur le banc des accusés ce
matin les 19 avocats du barreau de Dijon
concerné par cette affaire ont fait le
déplacement mais ils ont décidé de faire
grève et de l'afficher ils veulent le
retrait ou la révision de la loi
Macron c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important et ces principes que que cette
loi met en cause comme l'indépendance et
indirectement le secret professionnel
c'est des principes absolument
essentiels de des principes de
démocratie et c'est c'est on ne peut pas
tolérer cela alors c'est nous qui
portons ce combat mais encore une fois
il concerne tout le monde c'est ça c'est
ça qu'il faut bien comprendre ce n'est
pas un combat corporatiste la cour
d'assise de chumon n'a pas d'autre choix
que de reporter l'audience un report qui
n'est pas sans conséquence près de 120
personnes se sont constitué parties
civiles des parties civiles qui
attendaient beaucoup de ce procès leurs
avocats en ont bien conscience nous ne
sommes pas des nantis nous nous battons
pour un combat qui est juste nous nous
battons pour l'existence même de
l'avocat et nos clients le comprennent
les premiers je suis désolé que celui
qui porte la parole au nom de la société
dont nous sommes tous membres ne partage
pas cette vision avec nous et nous
renvoie vers une culpabilité qui n'a pas
lieu d'être l'avocat général a rappelé à
la cour que des milliers d'euros étaient
en jeu en première instance 200000 €
avaient été dépensé pour organiser ce
procès hors norme la présidente de la
Cour a demandé à Rémi cuculinski s'il
comprenait
la situation l'accusé a répondu oui elle
a enfin précisé que l'audience serait
donc reportée de 6 mois voire un
an